dunkle materie und dunkle energie sind
der menschheit trotz intensiver
forschungen immer noch ein riesiges
rätseln doch jetzt ist japanischen
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern ein vielleicht
entscheidender schritt gelungen mit
hilfe eines exotischen teilchens hat das
forschungsteam eine überraschend stabile
form neuer materie kreiert ein wirklich
irrsinnig spannendes experiment klicks
um science-fiction gibt es jeden tag ein
neues science video abonnierte kanal
dann und nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
herzlich willkommen obwohl die existenz
der dunklen materie bereits vor 80
jahren vorhergesagt wurde gehört ihre
zusammensetzung wohl weiterhin zu den
wichtigsten ungeklärten fragen der
physik und kosmologie wir haben es hier
also quasi mit dem heiligen gral der
modernen naturwissenschaften zu tun um
es noch einmal deutlich zu machen
lediglich 17 prozent der gesamten masse
des weltraums besteht wohl aus
sogenannter biologischer materie also
der materie die wir kennen
der überwiegende rest ist noch unbekannt
und wird somit eben oft als dunkle
materie bezeichnet um diese ungelösten
fragen der kosmologie endlich zu
beantworten suchen forschungsteams
weltweit nach allen möglichen teilchen
die theoretisch existieren könnten immer
auf der spur nach den ultimativen
bausteinen des kosmos mit hilfe von
teilchenbeschleunigern wird materie
immer weiter in immer kleinere partikel
zerlegt die große hoffnung
zusammengesetzt könnten diese vielen
mosaik stückchen irgendwann ein
gesamtbild vom universum zu seiner
entstehung und zusammensetzung liefern
in diesem zusammenhang hat ein
japanisches forschungsteam jetzt einen
erfolg verbucht und er ist wirklich
absolut irrsinnig die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
nutzen dazu einen teilchenbeschleuniger
am forschungskomplex seepark etwa 120
kilometer nördlich von tokio am proton
axxelerate research komplex werden
protonen derzeit auf 30
gigaelektronenvolt beschleunigt konkret
ging es um ein sehr exotisches teilchen
das sogenannte anti caron kurz zur
erklärung karonen sind mittelschwere
subatomare teilchen die sich aus zwei
quarks zusammensetzen
genau genommen aus einem quark
antiquariat eigentlich findet man sie
nur in teilchenbeschleunigern und in
kleiner
anzahl auch in der kosmischen strahlung
schon seit einiger zeit geht die
fachwelt davon aus dass ko nnen eine
bestimmte wirkung im atomkern haben
könnten doch entsprechende experimente
zu dieser annahme lieferten keine
eindeutigen ergebnisse bis jetzt der
aktuelle erfolg gelang dem japanischen
forschungsteam in dem ein neutronen in
einem helium 3 isotop durch ein anti
caron ersetzt wurde
denn so gelang es tatsächlich eine
stabile form neuer materie zu kreieren
bei der exzellent wurde das helium 3
isotop mit hoch energetischen antipoden
beschossen wird dabei bei diesem bonmot
ein neutron exakt getroffen wird es aus
dem kern des atoms herausgeschlagen und
das antica und nimmt seinen platz ein
eigentlich sollten die beiden protonen
die somit nicht mehr aneinander gebunden
sind auseinander fliegen doch das antica
und verhindert dass da es selbst mit den
beiden protonen eine stabile einheit
bildet also ein vollkommen neuer atom
kern dieser neu gebildete kern cluster
war sogar für das forschungsteam selbst
eine riesige überraschung wie das
neutron hält das exotische teilchen die
beiden protonen zusammen und generiert
einen gebundenen zustand wirklich
erstaunlich dabei sei das das anti- ko
nnen im kern als eigenständiger baustein
existiert die sorgen nicht nur dafür
dass der atomkern stabiler ist als
bislang angenommen sondern auch für eine
enorme bindungsenergie so die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
auch wenn der neu entstandene kern
cluster nicht wirklich lange stabil ist
konnte also seine extrem hohe
bindungsenergie gemäß werden diese
erkenntnisse ermöglicht es den
fachleuten also kern materie mit hoher
dichte zu erzeugen diese bei annähernd
normal temperaturen weiter zu
untersuchen ein vielleicht erster
bedeutsamer schritt um beispielsweise
den aufbau massereicher neutronensterne
zu verstehen und ich finde es schon
absolut bahn brechen dass hier wirklich
eine neue art der materie ja quasi
entwickelt wurde und dass das
tatsächlich möglich ist das könnte die
suche nach der dunkle materie vollkommen
für neue perspektiven öffnen dunkle
materie die suche nach dem unsichtbaren
noch mehr zu diesem thema findet ihr
also wenn ihr hier auf dieses video
klickt bei doktor watson unbedingt drauf
kriegen ansehen und abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran